this video is sponsored by raycon
the art of critiquing has probably
existed since the beginning of man when
one neanderthal turned to another while
looking at some of the very first cave
paintings ever created and said
[Music]
which roughly translates to yeah the
light novel was better games movies
books
all these mediums have a pretty
fail-safe formula when it comes to
reviewing
you play watch or read the title in
question then you give your opinion on
it
sometimes you can even add a little
score at the end so you can give
everyone a reason to skip your actual
review and just summarize all your
nuanced opinions into a single numerical
value
hey would you look at that has a little
something for everyone in recent times
reviewing outlets have become somewhat
of a controversial topic especially if
they come from some sort of mainstream
media outlets but you can't deny that
they do have an effect on their industry
it's an art form that has given people
careers good review scores can have a
tangible effect on sales and hype but
compared to other mediums anime review
seems to be in this unique spot
in that nobody really gives a [ __ ] about
them
hi i'm giggup and today i'm going to be
talking about a topic no one really
cares about
for a problem that doesn't actually
matter anime reviews is something i'll
always hold near and dear to my heart
because
well it's where i found a lot of my
early anime and it's also where i found
my own beginnings hey welcome to my
first anime review
and today i'll be reviewing bleach this
is the first video i
ever created that i originally posted on
youtube over 13 years ago it's a review
of leech like scripted
recorded and edited in a day and it is
an atrocity a pathetic attempt made by
some 17 year old kid trying to do his
best zero punctuation impression
recorded with a 5
usb mic making a bare bones windows
movie maker google image slideshow
and worst of all i gave bleach a 7 out
10. but you may be wondering what the
big difference is between younger giga's
shitty opinion about anime and
older gigan's shitty opinion about anime
well young giga thought he knew what he
was talking about because he had anime
protagonist hair
back then anime reviews were the staple
of anime critiques online
i can't count the number of new animes i
discovered back then just because of
specialized review sites and myself
trying to look for shows with high
review scores
damn this has a 4 star on them anime
reviews and an a on a
n [ __ ] i better give this show a try
right now though i feel like anime
reviews are in this weird spot in that
they are kind of just a non-factor in
our community this is certainly not an
attack on anyone still
doing anime reviews nor am i saying that
they've completely disappeared either
but i feel like they have barely any
impact compared to other mediums with
most of the stuff we see being closer to
analysis and editorials
and i feel there are a few reasons for
this unlike
games or movies there isn't as big of a
wall to overcome that consumers need to
commit to in order to consume the
product
for games it's a paywall you want to
know if a game is worth dishing out 60
dollars before you get it and with
movies you generally want to make sure
there isn't a waste of time and money to
go out and get a movie ticket and taking
out a second mortgage to get the
corresponding popcorn and drink set
compared to that who really needs a full
review when you just chuck on an episode
or two of an anime you're interested in
to see if it's a show you want to fully
commit to watch there isn't that same
barrier as there was before of having to
buy
physical dvds or even just finding and
downloading torrents was more time and
effort
at least more time and effort than
looking at review scores because now
shows are literally one click away but
not only that
by the time you can even properly review
some of the hottest newest anime
everyone's already moved on to give a
show a fair review it's common sense to
well watch the entire thing but for the
new shows by the time it's fully aired
and you get your review out to general
audiences it's like oh
what's that you reviewed the show that's
cool i'm already like watching the next
season though and i find this has a
unique effect on our community compared
to others
we don't have a metacritic or rotten
tomatoes giving us a metric score of
curated critics and because of this a
lot of hype is completely community
driven even with how much more
popular anime has gotten but what this
means is that what ends up getting
watched isn't necessarily the best shows
it's just what can make the most noise
as quickly as possible but beyond this
it is hard to review anime in the
traditional sense compared to mediums
like games or movies
and recently there's been two shows in
particular that have really made me
think about the reason for this
attack on titan and re-zero let's start
with attack on titan if you've seen my
video attack on titan is incredible now
you'll probably know my opinion on the
series and if you haven't you can still
probably guess that my opinion is that
it's incredible
now last year this is the show that
absolutely blew me away
there are a few words i can use to
describe just how good this show has
become and how much it's filled its
potential
every season has been building on its
previous foundation then consistently
exceeding itself time after time after
time
after time and just when you think it
can't get any better it
does it again and with the final season
just around the corner with every manga
reader hyping it up is even better than
everything that came before
i honestly feel this could have the
potential to become the
era defining anime but if you had asked
me what i thought seven years ago during
the four year long wait before season 2
i would have said
attack on titan yeah he was alright it
was a fun ride but that was pretty much
it i don't want to repeat myself too
much from what i've already said
because there's also re-zero now if
you've seen my video re-zero is no
masterpiece
but it's still damn entertaining you
probably know my opinion on the series
and if you don't you can still probably
take a guess
it's no masterpiece but it's still damn
entertaining
are we really doing this right now i
very much enjoyed re zero but ultimately
it didn't leave too deep an impression
on me
my main problem was that things just
seemed to be happening for no reason
it didn't feel like there was a main
driving force to the plot or
any overarching goal the biggest thing i
left with was subaru suffering about 20
different ways it was a fun ride but
once it ended it just felt
empty the world was hella interesting
and the character seemed great but i
didn't know what the core plot was
i didn't know what everything was meant
to be leading up to and while there has
been way more discourse highlighting the
new answers around its world and themes
and what the show was trying
to say my opinion has remained largely
the same for those reasons
fast forward to now we have half of
season 2 out and it's already addressed
some of the biggest issues i had a grand
plot with goals is becoming clearer we
have somewhat of an antagonist group now
subaru has been given time to really
develop as a character and we have way
more of an understanding of his
motivations and why he acts the way he
does
all the scattered pieces seem to be
forming into a coherent hole and on top
of all that
you have echidna best girl [ __ ] you i'm
sorry beatrice
but at the same time now that we're
given a glimpse of the sheer scale of
this world and the story i
very much doubt season 2 will even come
close to showing everything this series
has to offer but the more i see the more
i am absolutely impressed with
if you look at the journey i've had with
both these series you start to see a
very similar pattern
i was left with a concrete opinion that
remained for years which eventually got
shattered when a lot of the pitfalls i
originally had
were completely addressed or solved in
later seasons
many more of the subtle nuances in the
plot become clearer sometimes
recontextualizing massive events we
never gave a second thought to
which can completely change the way i
view a show now that a season isn't
being judged in its own bubble
which begs the question was it fair to
judge a series that i knew was
incomplete or were the problems i even
had valid in the first place
and when i thought about it like that i
realized that i could apply this to the
vast majority of anime that i watch
the reality is these series never
existed in a bubble they always had a
manga or light novel that continued the
story and explored it in greater depth
than any short season ever could
re zero season 1 was barely a prologue
but if you're an anime only watcher you
had no choice but to judge it on its own
but my god does this breed the most
toxic interactions when it comes to
anime only critiques versus manga
readers
one of the most annoying things you
encounter in this community is this
notion that if you're not completely
caught up to date with the title and
every medium it's available in
then any criticisms or opinion you have
completely become invalidated
plot holes are dressed in later volumes
annoying characters oh well they have
this flashback 200 chapters later that
makes some less of a [ __ ]
any conceivable problem you can have
with anything regarding the series
nope go read the source material you are
wrong
there will always be a disconnect
between manga and light novel readers
and anime only watchers but there must
be a happy medium where we can all
see eye to eye like on one hand i do
think any adaptation should be judged on
its own merits divorced from the source
material but
on the other hand i think it's important
to recognize from both sides that most
adaptations
are and always have been incomplete i've
talked before about how as an anime fan
you get used to getting invested in
worlds and stories that you may never
and probably will never see the ending
of and a lot of the times those stories
hardly even scratch the surface
fireflies has gone down in history as a
cult classic of a great television
program that got shafted way too early
leaving an incomplete story but
for us anime fans that's the norm it's
like if the vast majority of games you
ever played were in early access and
you'd never know if you'd be able to get
to play the finished product
sometimes you can wait a [ __ ] decade
and out of nowhere a new patch gets
announced but
even then it'll still be far from the
finished product
now imagine if eighty percent of every
game you ever played was like that
well that's what it's like to be an
anime fan and it probably always will be
as a lot of these shows are just seen as
glorified advertisements for the source
material
maybe anime fans and manga readers were
destined to never see eye to eye
maybe traditional review outlets were
never meant to be a big part of our
community i just find it funny how
despite anime is growing closer to
mainstream every year this is one of the
big difference that seems to remain
look i don't want you to get the wrong
idea about everything i've said am i
trying to say that
every review on mao is essentially
worthless yes but that's okay because it
means all our reviews are as worthless
as each other
i'm kind of glad there's no centralized
critic or media outlets and all the hype
is for the most
part community driven we may have
people's opinion who you listen to and
trust
but that's likely because it was built
up over time rather than just because
they were paid by an organization
and that just means the focus on our
community isn't to find the most highly
respected and acclaimed anime
but just the shows that resonate with
you and your taste
because if there's a medium for every
taste this is it
i don't pretend to be a reviewer anymore
a lot of people misunderstand my videos
as
oh hey giga get another positive review
for another show
he just hypes up every show well firstly
these aren't reviews i just want to
share some [ __ ] i like or find
interesting and secondly no [ __ ] i'm
gonna talk about them positively have
you seen how many shows we have to pick
from nowadays
it's 20 20 who the [ __ ] has time to
waste by watching things they don't like
anymore back when i started
anime reviews held more weight because
more often than not we were talking
about things we'd already finished and
you did have to go out and spend money
to watch them
or at the very least run the risk of
getting your dad's laptop and std on
limewire nowadays no one needs a
traditional review of demon slayer or my
hero academia because everyone's already
seen them and everyone can
watch them so easily so the audience for
reviews or basically nowadays more
likely discussions of modern series
aren't people looking to see if
something's worth their time it's often
looking for an opinion to compare theirs
to
waiting for that number at the end so
they can shout about how bad the
reviewer is
or let's be real waiting for that sweet
old validation baby
yeah that's right you know what i mean
have no fear your opinion's correct
someone on the internet told you so did
you hear that mom
maybe you know what it feels like one
day synthetic fans in conclusion i guess
what i was trying to say is this video
is kind of stupid four out of ten go
read the manga for full context
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video i
just want to give a quick thank to the
sponsor of today's video
raycon look you're not a guy who skips
anime ops are you
if you'd like to listen to your anime
ops and listen to your other anime music
on the go then raycon earbuds are the
perfect thing
just for that they are half the price as
most other premium earbuds on the market
while sounding
just as good they give you six hours of
play time seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass and a more compact design for
a comfortable noise isolating fit this
is the model i have it's the everyday
e25 version so look you can see here
they're available in a wide range of
colors which you can get
on their website okay i'm going to be
real b for a sec these are actually my
second pair of raycons i left my first
pair in my jean pockets and accidentally
put them in the wash but i like these so
much that i had to get myself a second
pair and if you're just looking for
something casual
and easy to use then i really can't
recommend this more
so if you want to give these bad boys a
girl you can click the link in the
description or go to buy
recon dot com slash giggup for 20 off
your purchase
that's by raycon dot com slash gig up
for 20
off and now is the best time to get them
because this deal is only offered for a
limited time
and yeah that's just about it i'm gonna
be real i'm really tired as i'm filming
this right now so
i'm just gonna keep it quick and simple
that was the video hope you enjoyed it
i've been giggup
and i will see you all next time
i'm [ __ ] dying inside